I think it's really really unfortunate
and dangerous that she said that and I I
I don't need to co-host with her again
yeah that's Meghan McCain throwing some
serious shade at Elizabeth Hasselbeck
after she said Americans should pray
away the corona virus
anybody who's screwing around with this
virus and putting out sort of
misinformation I just I don't really
have a lot of time for right now here's
what went down back in March the Vieux
alum returned to the show to guest
co-host and said this I think we should
prepare I think we should pray I'm not
gonna let coronavirus rule me and this
and I do think our leadership right now
is pointing us to say hey this is not a
panic situation this is a precautionary
situation we're gonna use pearl pure
I'll wash our hands Hargitay okay I
would not be a panic situation when you
have people dying from this yeah Megan
no likey a few days later she had this
to say about all that I think instead we
should implore the executives at Fox
News have god forbid anything ever like
this happens again to put more doctors
on air with some of these pundits who
are you know I'm not a doctor I'm not
saying I'm a doctor I never have but
putting in place medical professionals
who know what they're talking about
reminder here Elizabeth left the view
for a spot on Fox News back in 2013
Republicans saying that it was you know
that we should wash our hands and pray
it away so it wasn't just on Fox News
but it was happening it happened right
here in the view so naturally when
Meghan appeared on watch what happens
live with Andy Cohen on Wednesday night
Andy just had to ask about the whole
thing what were your thoughts on
Elisabeth Hasselbeck co-hosting the view
and saying we should pray the virus away
yeah somebody actually sent me a
screenshot of my face when she said that
I was you know I took this virus
seriously from the very beginning and I
thought a lot of this rhetoric was
really dangerous and I think it's really
really unfortunate and dangerous that
she said that and I I don't need to
co-host with her again oh damn and it's
unfortunate because I've been a huge fan
for a long time and anybody who's
screwing around with this virus and
putting out sort of misinformation I
just I don't really have a lot of time
for right now she's straight up just
said it ain't nobody got time for that
a lot of time pouring out anyway and he
also asked the Republican TV personality
if Joe Biden has her vote for president
I love him dearly and it well I I keep
telling everyone I will promise you you
will know who I'm voting for but it
really shouldn't take a rocket scientist
to know there's one man who has made
pain in my life a living hell and
another man who was like literally
Shepherd me through the grief process
this really shouldn't be rocket science
for people and just in case you can't
read between the lines President Donald
Trump is the man who has made her life
hell and the Democratic presidential
nominee is said Shepard she's just been
so integral in my life especially since
my dad got sick so I'm always like my
heart over my head in so many different
ways and the Trump's like are always
putting my they're always making my mom
cry Megan's dad US Senator John McCain
who died in 2018 was a longtime friend
of Joe and famously butt heads with
Trump on repeat politics is personal to
it and it's and I think character is
really important in this moment and
someone who's gonna tamp down and I was
actually talking to Eric about this
someone who can tamp down fear and anger
instead of instead of making it worse
[Music]
you